freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video ein frühstück mit jeremy jenkins r
hier neben mir dass man in saint-paul
heute nicht
vielleicht kriegen wir auch am besten
dass im laufe des tages wir haben ganz
viele zutaten und germany wird gleich
entscheidend was du bereitet wird es gab
nur noch einen zwischenfall gegeben
seht ihr selbst wegen jetzt finden wir
wollten eigentlich gerade einfach zu
drehen aber ging nach morning sprints
immer und sie müssen seien bisher mache
ich jetzt mit zurück ja ich möchte euch
jetzt ist man auch anders erst mal ein
kilo parmesan jamie macht weiter seien
routine
[Musik]
du machst das schon okay aber das krieg
ich nicht machen kriegen wenig weit ich
runter kommt
[Musik]
man merkt man wird wach auf jeden fall
ja jetzt mal ein bisschen fußball das
update noch mal okay
[Musik]
hilft mich also mein ernährungsplan ist
derzeit wie folgt ich mal ganz fest so
ich frühstücke relativ spät vorher weil
ich nicht mit matsch zu und mit grünen
themen sucht die erste mahlzeit ist
meistens eier und fisch und dazu baller
ich basilikum petersilie und links aber
keine karte 0,00 prozent acht eier und
fisch zum frühstück sonst nichts nichts
du bist ja jemand der sehr
wissenschaftlich alternativen zur
ernährung hat genießt du essen ich
genieße alle mahlzeiten außer der ersten
also quasi genießt die benefits vom
essen sozusagen genießt nicht das essen
selbst weil dein gehirn reagiert ja
schon mehr auch so fetthaltig
zuckerhaltig gaddafi also so weit müssen
wir uns schon unter kontrolle haben
wobei es gar nicht so einfach ist weil
das ja eine sehr ekstatische sache sein
kann vor allem mit den hochgezüchteten
auch süßen lebensmitteln die wir
mittlerweile haben aber ich liebe eier
und fisch dann haben wir ein magerquark
metz protein vollbart dann haben wir
eine riesenschüssel gemüse mit organen
von hühnern und so erzeugt und dann
abends habe ich nur meinen augsburg
abendessen ok ok guck mal lasst uns
schauen du hast gesagt kann man aeros
müssen noch schön scharf drei stück
darum weil da capsaicin drin ist dass
die verdauung anregt ein hunger stillt
ja und richtig vitamin c und den arsch
weg bringt das brennt den hochständen
abschreckt also wenn wir die dinger
gleich ist dann siehst du und du dir
damals irgendwie ins gesicht fasst
bisschen brennt er guckt mal ansonsten
lasse zu denen kleine sind keine nüsse
warum zu viel ich habe das in einem
wissen weg und ich wickeln wie zwei kilo
mehr
dann können wir direkt zur seite jetzt
aber uninteressant ich mochte
mach dich hier aber es ist jetzt nicht
so ein must-have dann guck mal da habe
ich mich gefragt ist das was für mich
das finde ich geil weil das würde ich
gerne kenne ich alle verdienen kann
nicht alles aber kariya hatte ich noch
nie zum frisch wir kommen dann würde ich
das nicht alles super quelle von omega 3
ich weiß natürlich wie gesund die dinge
sind ja nur so wie gestern habe ich habe
mir gedacht umwelt ausmachte
dann können wir vielleicht in kaviar
drüber machen das hätte dann können wir
machen oder wir essen die wachteleier
habe ich auch früher gemacht und jetzt
finde ich mit der schale doch mit
scarlett rochat okay also ich habe mir
vorgenommen ich esse alles was du isst
aber so ein rosbach 3
würdet ihr den vortritt lassen
tatsächlich macht putin auch schoko
costa laurenz franzbrötchen nix weißes
brötchen nenne 8 ich hab gut aufgepasst
dickel vollkommen sauerteigbrot geil
aber erst abends erst abends okay dann
lassen wir das jetzt aus dem topf
gesteckt und komplett
ok nichts darf ich dir mal in der wunsch
risko sterbe alles super was du brauchst
geil viel vitamin c und auch stimmst du
nicht so sehr das desinfiziert auch dein
mund wenn du gewürz mir schon mit
knoblauch und so hier ist ganz toll ihn
drin so für deinen ballaststoffe für
deinen bauch richtig geil die nehmen wir
jetzt auch anstelle der zwiebeln weil
die haben das ähnliche dinge müssen wir
jetzt nicht zum frühstück kam habe ich
eher so nachmittags in heute auch geld
fahne ok ansonsten war geil nächste
eigentlich nicht mehr weil die haben
auch zucker morgens echt nur komplett
neutral und was haben wir noch kw als
supernova
also ich brate immer ohne fett aber
schuss kannst du dir dann reichen also
was hier dinge der einzigen quellen von
vitamin d für vegetarier veganer bauen
wir auch rein sehr gut ab aber sie hat
ja irgendwie 30 30 gramm fett oder
sonntag weißt du wieviel fett ein hai
hat die sieben gramm fett ab kreis
können hier eier essen locker oder einer
vokabel was was ist mehr bennet meyer
ich glaube ja
macht weil das habe ich noch nie da sie
ist der song bester form nur noch eine
schüssel habe ich hier thema wird
germany wo in aller welt beziehst du
diese informationen liefern hilfen
schaftliche publikation ist er einer
meiner lieblings tests immer wenn ich
was gegessen habe ist ich putze mir die
zähne mit der anderen hand wie ich
eigentlich benutzt und rückwärts die
treppen hoch auch so ein bisschen unter
den bieren kombinationen und dann merkst
du four ich finde ich nicht so schlecht
so werk fühle ich mich ja und so teste
ich mich auch nochmal ich merke gerade
ich zum ersten mal mit wachtel ein
bisschen schwer im handling also klein
irgendwann hast du eine schere erstmal
ein normal es gibt sogar so richtige
wachteleier scheren ansonsten macht
einfach so europas mit der schale ist
egal wenn wir mal eigentlich geht das
besser zum einen geht mit schall das
macht arnold schwarzenegger auf kannst
du gucken denn sonst ein bisschen
traditionell kulinarisch unterwegs also
ich hab so viel auf rezepte zurück aber
du machst das genau richtig merkt es
schon es ist gibt will man da jetzt 36
stück weit da noch mal was ist das geil
meint das ist energy pro das ist immer
so ein arzt aus amerika der sagt die
jung of texas at york also es gäbe ist
so sehr wahrscheinlich das gesündeste
was es gibt auf der welt eine
multivitamin tablette was ist in einem
drin es natürlich halt ne test ist
einfach ein teil meiner morning und ines
stöhr aus dem kühlschrank mining wasser
reines wasser mit hochkonzentrierten
extrakte ok und dann trinke ich das und
dann dein magen wie so eine maschine
dich an flutlicht weiter schwierig war
und dann fange ich an zähne zu putzen so
schon sodann rasiere ich mich nächste
termin
ich habe eine frage an dich dann gesagt
kommen eine stunde drehte power power
braucht ja danach gehst du direkt weiter
heißt du dich jeden tag so busy und so
aktiv oder hast du eine zeit ab der den
ruhemodus geste und dann machst du gar
nichts mehr und nichts ist das dann
einfach eine ecke rage estate sozusagen
eine mutige stimmung anstelle einer
feigen aufmerksam wo man so kopf mäßig
da ist ne also im prinzip will smith hat
mal gesagt die junge garde bio
wenn du dich freiwillig diesen sachen
stehst bist du viel geiler drauf wir
werden das jetzt alles mal schön wenn
man jetzt sieht man so die schale eine
der besten kalzium quellen die es gibt
auch das selbstläufer ja ja wobei war da
mal weil du willst nicht zu viel salz
haben weil sonst ist sein gesicht sehr
abwickler und fisch hat von natur aus
immer viel zeit nehmen wir nur das
palaver normal trinke ich dazu immer
noch eine grüne bank aus dem bierkrug
mal fällt deswegen esse ich auch die
sardinen mit haut und knochen ihr weil
die kollegen die knappen an kollagen
einmal so ein staatseingriff regeln das
heißt du nimmst recht ich bin drei
spiele kein problem sommer die vielen
ich mache das meist parallel ja bist du
ein brötchen messer oder machst du von
halt macht die so einmal sauber und der
rest geht leicht weg wenn ich das mit
wasser hier weg gemacht habe okay ich
schon den nächsten ging an so scharfe
schauen aber jetzt wenn die eine alter
schwede was ist aus seinem auch bei mir
so japan ihr kleid auf jeden fall ja ja
dein größter feind ist die komfortzone
neues gefühl kann das sein was machst du
wenn du in der komfortzone das für mich
ein traum volkszorn ist wenn ich im
flugzeug sitze und einfach tanner
übrigens geht auch nicht mehr essen
punkt also ganz kurz für die leute wie
das girlie fragrance wachtel komplett
mit zubereiten wollen paar zitate pilze
in die butter schmalz ja und das braten
wir jetzt einfach ein bisschen an dann
kommt im anschluss wachte rührei drauf
und abschotten auch rein ja machen wir
so kommen wir mal zum essen du gehst
nicht essen du isst sehr funktional
kommt es mal vor dass sich ein burger
mit pommes rein knallten nicht mehr ich
war ja in miami und da habe ich alles
ausprobiert aber ist das ist das für
dich fit ohne ende und geil und ich habe
es gemacht habt jetzt rechts irgendwann
weil wir wissen das kannst du nicht mal
denkst du manchmal dass du dich so viel
selbst optimiert dass du quasi den fokus
mehr auf dem optimieren also auf den
eigentlichen zielen hast oder schafft es
seine ziele immer im fokus zu behalten
ich habe verschiedene sachen ausprobiert
ich wollte diese sache mit dem essen
gerne einmal und für alle mal erledigt
haben ich habe auch nicht
viele video weiß man ja ja weil wir tun
das jeden tag der viermal ja ein leben
lang du weißt es ja selber wie du dich
fühlst nach einer katastrophalen
mahlzeit ja vorhin überlegt du hast vier
katastrophale mahlzeiten den nächsten 20
jahre jeden tag so machst du das bett
von unseren tellern fertig also wir
machen einfach hälfte hälfte magst du
deinen ort so ein bisschen dran ihr ja
gerne gerne das wird mir schwer ich merk
stark gemacht es ist so voll mit
artischocken herzen passt wir werden
keinen schönheitspreis gewinnen kein
problem wir machen das hier und jeder
kriegt drei stück die kommen hier drauf
her und hier kommt dann der wisch normal
hin und die drei eier fisch also kaviar
2 du hast gewürze was ist italienische
kräuter ohne ende
oh ja ich habe sie auf dem balkon
frischen oregano rosmarin ich mach
meistens hier einfach voll die ladung
pizza gewürz drauf hast du so was ja mit
sicherheit wartet er jetzt gestreut und
ich mache auch viel und dann noch
frischen pfeffer noch nicht nochmal
dritten tarif würde ich auch noch mal
machen bin sehr gespannt wie das
schmeckt ist jetzt das ist normal man
weiß alles ist voll die tops für deinen
körper fit wird ist geil ich mir so
gespannt ob das nach irgendwas schmecken
wird wird komm du musst dir wirklich
augenscheinlich es so ich will bild
jetzt normal nennen aber ich sage mal
traditionell also für mich ist das jetzt
gerade eine ganz andere welt hier warst
du mir und diese gläser für die grünen
kommt nicht die klassik gab an erst mal
weg da war alles für dich gekauft also
feel free machst du wenn du mit ihr als
rein das passt genau für uns zwei
portionen ihr seht bisschen partnern
hier rein wie gesagt ganz viel quer
zieht ihn drin das ist total der
gesunden antioxidantien aber ich habe
mir direkt beim kaviar gedacht dass das
was für dich ist hälfte bei uns beiden
jeweils oben auf die kräuter oder an die
seite die machen wir fest was ich noch
gerne zu hätte im opera dienen dose weil
das sind so ein bisschen wenig deutsch
leber oder es sind kieler sprotten ja es
geht in ordnung das waren die einzigen
ganzen fische walknochen müssen dabei
sein müssen das öl aber abtropfen ihr
kleiner der fisch desto wenig mercury
und quecksilber und so ein zeug hat er
in sich glaube ich die hier nicht
den teller ja den effekt die findet
nämlich irgendwie richtig geil noch mal
habe ich jetzt nur so vitamintabletten
und so ein zeug das ich habe glaube ich
magnesiumtabletten würde ich gern neben
nach dem sprint ich will genau das
gleiche wie du ich will genau sagen
start sein ok cherie
es ist soweit aus jetzt kommt drauf an
du hast das schon häufig gegessen ich
habe das noch nie gegessen ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen wenn ich das so in dem
restaurant kriegen würde würde ich ihn
vielleicht ein vogel zeigen einfach rein
damit und fertig wir fangen erst mal mit
einem dankes gewählt an vielen dank
lieber gott für das wundervolle essen
hier mit max von mit eric hinter der
kamera und dass wir hier etwas
wundervolles genießen dürfen
[Musik]
ok dann kommt lacht ja ich trinke dann
meist als erstes meine vitamintabletten
hier die irgendwie so legen so von
leonardo da vinci nach einem
arbeitsreichen tag schläft man
wundervoll
nach einem arbeitsreichen leben steht
man wundervoll und nach unserem sprint
und den ganzen arbeit arbeit arbeit ich
sage immer 80 prozent vom frühstück
erledigt haben schmeckt das auch wenn es
nicht so schmecken würde ich bin
gespannt
gründer beziehen sondern schmecken geht
erst mal neutral als eigentlich schocken
herz mit einem kilo italienische kräuter
und kann dir empfehlen schau dass du die
habanos über decks mit den anderen
geschmäckern weil alleine wenn du die
ist der raum ledig weggang nicht weg
aber nero auberginen herz kaviar und
natürlich italienische volk und danach
kannst du marathon laufen nach diesen
essen wo wir jetzt mal das machte leider
ist auch so ein stückchen schade kommt
nehme ich das mal für die kamera mit
schade darf auch nicht fehlen
mich würde es jetzt nur weil du da bist
sonst würde ich das niemals essen aber
vielleicht zeigt zum ersten mal
irgendwie nicht darunter war mir einfach
kalzium vielleicht finde ich nicht so
gut weil ich gucke einmal was drin ist
dann geht's rein ja ja vielleicht wäre
das doch mal was für dich auch mal koch
wieder raus so haben die leute
interessieren sich doch deine ernährung
ich hab so ein bisschen einen internen
kodex dass es auch regeln zur leitet
sein sollte darf man da drüben oder
schon irgendwer steht schon eine kleine
kollektion bei die werden mir in einem
video von dir jetzt gleich mal schnell
durch carolina klar derzeit auf jeden
fall bei dem mit vorbeischauen kann muss
ich sagen mein magen wehrt sich ein
bisschen gerade ich bin das nicht
gewohnt
vielleicht kann als bei ihr musst du die
abonnieren besser vorher machen als
später leute ich glaube wir haben immer
den eindruck gesehen ist wirklich tracy
ich bin gespannt wie ich mich fühle
vielleicht werde ich mich noch mal zu
wort ich trinke ja noch ein stück von
hühnerbrühe macht gute leute
es ist noch viel zu krank was wir hier
auf diesen teller hatten ich habe mich
mehr geschafft hat ich hatte wirklich
geschafft germany ist jetzt weg das hier
ist ein reseller
was soll ich sagen also es war nicht
lecker musste auch schon abstecher ins
bad machen bin ich jetzt voll am start
bin auf jeden fall nach dem morgen mit
jeremic deshalb hat es auf jeden fall
sein ziel erfüllt will ich sagen jedem
fall
danke dass ihr zugeschaut hat war
wirklich ein außerordentliches video
heute und wir sehen uns natürlich zu
ganz normalen koch videos bald wieder
aber ich glaube es war wirklich sehr
cool heute zu sehen
[Musik]